[Music]
next i'd like to welcome our second
speaker
dr daisy chen dr chen is the director of
the beijing institute of heptology
dr chen take it away hello
good afternoon everyone my name is
i'm from beijing institute of hepatology
i am very happy to be invited by merc to
join this
sparrow congress on the kind of wireless
disease
19 which is very valuable and will play
gradually
increasing economic changing and improve
the knowledge and research level of
account non-awareness
disease 19 communication now i will
report all study in canon virus disease
19 my topic is characteristic
autonomic immuno change in severe
patients with a virus mentioned
we know cannot win canon virus 19 caused
by
sas channel virus 2 have a glue
into the global public housing emergency
problem
sas virus 2
s protein binding to the pce 2 receptor
are human epicellular cells
the high ability of the s protein
for human ec2 may lead to the
great human human transmission of such
converge
too irresponsible sucks nowhere to
infection infect the cell
promotes the separation of large amounts
of
hemokin and acetyl key which were
reported in the controversy 19
severe cases similar to the similar to
sas and mars the positive presence of
cytokine storm may play a major role in
transgenesis
which causes inflammatory induced a lot
injury
and other complications our early study
in the severe patient showed that
in the early inpatients the
t cell and b-cell increased the
inhibition decreased and
the macrophage group
has given the increase after
treatment is an idea of inpatient
issue b cell tcl
about nearly returned to the normal
level
and in sometimes macrophages
cells groups decrease to the normal
level too
and look like you know has control in
the website
this data publishing the agent disease
this gives us a question we need to know
what happened in this dynamic process
first question we want to know what
molecular signal possibly
is a critical e sub group of pbmc
dynamical changing
first we analyze the cytokine l2
4 6 10 17 tf
alpha and gamma
this associates is a inflammatory
process
at the earliest recurrence stage in
other severe
carnovirus disease 19 results show that
compared with math group out time level
was
higher in severe growth
at time level or partially correlated
with the early sixth level
leukocyte count neutrophil counts
interestingly i've found the initial
treatment
and time out group for significant drop
while still kept a similar level in
severe group
then we analyze the
70 is expression in pbmc
of scholarly virus disease naturally
with the biomarker system results show
that
a total of 63 thousand a massive ig
was expressing
in cell is severe group related to the
normal control group because the evan
which showed this is a severe
patient in the early stage and
sometimes modeled
this in the center of the mouth
group included 37 town regulatory genes
and two other teachings
showing b1 then we analyze
the cities how big different
which fund the 34 teams were overlapped
in the two groups and tangentines was
specific
to severe group dividing expressions
the rich term includes such as th17
cell differentiate cytokine might added
secondary
possibly cytokine connection neutral
killing cell migration toxicity and
t-cell
activation the tissue specific
pdi data were collected from the
different
net database using network and
analyze platform screen the key gene
involving immunology of a canon virus
19 showing red side d d
severe group as a math group person
uniform trend towards similarly reduced
different gene expression number after
initial treatment
this is severe
group of treatment he found this
result and b2 is a mild group
of treatment self boundaries results of
the genes
these similar reduced numbers of initial
treatment compared to aoi and b1
headlamp shows the class analysis for
the 27-12
eg for severe group and minor groups of
neutral treatment we analyze the
cell signal possibly in this different
stage and a different
treating time we find five digits
for coming among the a1 by a2 and the b2
group
which including gumb
fatc3 jacob hr
and pf who are very very
downregulated relative to the normal
control group
even no regular difference among all the
four groups
we show in the c and d this result then
we analyze the result with the set
with the set half we find is a
a1 and b1
this 2 you know a1 as a
severe group divides the mud group
in the early stage and even we showed
the severe group
in the early stage a lot of
t-cell and b-cell is a decrease
decrease but the macrophage
is increased and the
mud group looked like almost
in years you know the normal the
control levels after treatment
need to and recover to the
normal levels this suggests
this suggests the avenation treatment
the severe growth of the population cd40
cell
turned similar to normal control but
exclude t cell cd80
cells in the tcdt cell look like
still in low levels for mad group a
significantly
reduced t-cell the cd8 t-cell relative
to normal control
but all come back to the similar reason
normal control after measure treatment
conclusion in this part of funding
showed that a decreased t-cell
approaching
with down-regulated gene suppression
related to t-style
activation of the braces were occurred
in
canovirus disease 19 severe globes
which might help to provide effective
treatment
in strategy for cannon virus disease 19
this was published in clinical factory
disease
the second question which we want to
know which subgroup of pbmc
dynamic increase our decrease in severe
patient
recovery we study
this pbmc with mastormetry
and divide the 31 clusters
using metal labels antibodies against
the 18
immuno cell surface mark and observe
the difference in the composition of
cd45 protein preparation population
in health control and can awareness
disease
19 patients and different clinical
condition
a which from a left side to red side
shows 31 clusters
from health control mouth severe and
critical
will look like you show the in the
critical and severe is a
piston t cell significant decreased
the results show the cd4 cd8 cd45 ra and
the cd4 t5 r0cd
file cx are three
and cd 11p
displays a relatively more dynamic
dispersion
visual in the figure b compare the
housing control the percentage of the
subset
subset of immunocell represented by
each cluster and furthermore major
difference between has
control and patient well
there were no significant different
among the patients
of the mild severe greater capacity we
can show
that bigger sleep seeing we compared
those in the heart control we found that
the portion of this cell
cd4 cd double positive cell
and the niocity for positive cell and
tgf
beta positive cd28 negative niocd for t
cell in infected patients what
generally increased and you sometimes
see the itchy cell even
they belong to the effector our
nail our memory subset declined the cost
constantly during the progression of
infection
this means the ctr level significantly
decreased
then we compared you know the
health control mouth and severe
critical this four subgroup the
different cell type
from b cell dc to macrophage to the t
cell and nk cell
the result shows the inky cell monocyte
mtscs and t regular appear to show the
sympathy and the increase
during the progression from math to
severe condition
but then decline during progression
to critical condition we
observed that the approaches of this is
much fish cd4 prototype cell
and here beta 428
nail 50 28 negative 9 ocd 8
positive g cells or higher in the
microglobulin in the severe group
this means the severe group the immuno
you know the cd8 level and ctr
level special told them virus
significant decreased continually
see we compare t regular cell
and double positive t cell you show the
a and the b t rho c d 4 positive c 25
41 cp 127 negative
and b is the double proteot
cells is the cpu 25 negative
the result shows that the level of
function molecular such as the 6r3
cd28 and the tgf beta were
obviously higher in the patient group
presented in the control
health group generally compared to
amphibians
among health control and mouth and
severe and clinical is a different cells
including b cell dc to the t and the
cd40 and the cdc8t
cells the results show that increasing
expression degenerability among all the
patient group
occur in multiple table immuno cells
those conclusions like tdf beta
expression at the maximum increase would
be player critical rule
e central k stone t cell level
attenuation would play important role
in disease process because we find that
is always a cd8 t
cell level decreased
the third question we need to do the
dynamic plant
plasma shadow kings could be a bell
marker for severe
patient recovery
first we compare the normal forces
account
level in price control and
mild severe and the critical this for
group
are big different we find absorbs
absolute thermopolished count in patient
with the canon virus
disease 19 it was decreased
very significantly compared to normal
control
the lemon forces the level in white time
b
cells decrease in common serve and
credible patient
where the white have bc or what b
cells and neutrophil count
increased then we use the setup
compare normal control common patients
so we are patient a great patient in
their you know the
tissue piece of increased levels we
multiply the normal control cd4 t cell
and the cd t-cell and n-k-cell and the
b-cell
and the macrophylla cell and the double
positive t-cells these
look like this a lot of sub-clusters is
positive
then in the critical vision if almost
all of them are negative
especially macrophage the condition of
the pbmc
impeachment can avoid 19 we compare
normal and the mild
and severe again the critical we find
the percentage of
this cell or increase in severe and
acrylic
patient compared to normal control
increased cell
in common patients this means mild
patients
were higher than that the normal control
the ct cell the percentage was
significantly lower in patient with the
canal virus disease
especially the positive sedative t cell
in the critical
patient resources similar results
showing like like a before study is
special for certificates anti-varieties
are
decreased significantly see we look at
the you know the
cells as acetylene the difference we
first
look at the io2 we find that the
l2 level including patient signature
lower
saying that in severe patients where the
levels
are 2 is repetition higher than the
normal control and mild patients
for i have in gamma that's very
important
for the inflammatory control
inflammatory
it's another critical patient in
clinical patients to give the
2 compared to the common patients
the air tank and the l6 incrementation
were higher since that
incoming severe patient is a very lazy
this is very confusing result how to
explain
the the patient syndrome
so then we go look at
the output downstream of the
regulator genes this l2 receptor
alpha beta gamma and down regulate the
genes jacket and start
file signal which
we found that the downstream signal is
always decreased this gives us
suggesting that
l2 wire even the high level it doesn't
work
convolution the impression of i2
receptor jack 1 and the start of five
decreasing pbm is here for all
the other cd
connor various diseases 19 patients
but l2 level will elevate is severe
patient decrease in clogged patient
even increase we can because downstream
regulations decrease i think i'm
out who in this pathway is don't
work so secondly the decrease of ilo 8
cd8 t cell in critical patient
with the cannon virus 19 pneumonia
may be related to the il2 signal parsley
the inhibition of l2 l2 receptor virus
cdt cell and the normal forces decrease
through jacqueline stud file so signal
positive
equals patient with the conversion 19
pneumonia
in the cell the cdd
so this cell the cell cell deaths and
disease the fourth question is
we need to know the immune cells of
location with half different between the
peripheral blood we know from us
from pbmc we find the colonel wherein 19
patients the b cell and the t cell
significantly decreased even
is functional so we don't
know we need to know
is seen as a peripheral blood or
different
we use you know the
we use the mass term image cytometry
and compare the control patients of the
lung
tissue and canola virus
19 disease disease 19 and the
commercial canary various disease
managing cool infection with bacteria
in the patient's patients too
the results show that diffused
infiltration cd4 telomere faucet
a four core infiltrator increased cell
this shows that cd16
and cd107a pull two
and the diffused infiltration nitrogen
cell
is shown in cb45 ra and
cd4 all but
in the patient two is coin infection
with bacteria
this shows the infiltration of
nitro t cell and the scada
infiltration inc itself which was
different
from patient one thing
we look at the university 68
city 20 and see
cd25 from tcv city 1076
and the call into one compare common
con normal control and uh
position one only conventional virus
which is
19 and the patient 2
co-infection with the bacteria the
results show that the patient one has
cluster infiltration macrophage is a
group
with a cd68 positive and this is cd276.1
which distributed the difference from
microspeed and
one accompanied by a local old question
of
college one
patient two presenters got clusters in
filtration macrophage more dc
and the clear boundaries between
microfinance psychologists
then we look at the another cd 16
ct 11b and the argo 1
and the cd68 lcd 14 compare
in common control and the
canary versus disease 19 and the canary
canal virus disease 19
co-infection with bacteria the result
shows that
only canary virus disease
infection is a heart full of neutrophil
and activity that macrophage
cells is aggravamented this is cd14
but in the co-infection with the
bacteria there's a patient to show a
cluster
infiltration neutrophil cd11b and cd16
and activated macrophage ago and
dc cd40
conclusion all studies suggest that this
this infiltration mononuclear cell are
cd4
t cell since it is a natural killer cell
and
magnetic field cell recruitment of a
brain
cd45ra t cell in the immunological
feature of sclerovirus 19.
once bacterial pneumonia occur
some budget seed recreated
by cd4 t cell began to play a major role
in that injury the cd4 cell level and
the cta
network and the b cell level look like
it's very big diff
different compare critical efficiency in
the
pbmc so we give it through this
first four part study we give a summary
is
firstly the decreased t-cell group shift
will withdraw regulated genes depression
related to t-cell activation and
deviation
were occurred in canon virus 19
disease severe patient which
may help through the effective treatment
strategy
for conversion this is 19
tgf bits of always persian and micro
feed cell
increase would be a play a great growth
in settle kingston
tessa level attenuation would play an
important role in disease
process the inhibition of l2
receptors to see the eight t cell
and the lemon fourth decrease through
the jacobian starter file
cell signal partially in critical
patient
with the canonical pneumonia the last
one
which is the you know the tissue the
lung tissues
with by the recruitment of a burning
cd45
ra positive cell is a immunological
feature of sconovirus 19
once bacterial pneumonia occurs so
free acid recreated by cd4 t cells
beginning to play a major role in
injury thank you very much
for your attention